Oh
the world is a noisy place every day
were surrounded by rush-hour traffic
obnoxious neighbors countless planes
zipping by overhead it seems impossible
to get any peace and quiet in the modern
world in one of my previous videos we
learned about the loudest sound ever
made but what if you want it to be as
removed from sound as you could possibly
be believe it or not there are still
some places on earth that are so quiet
all you'll be able to hear is your own
ears ringing in this video we're going
to look at five of the absolute quietest
places on the planet the first stop on
our silent journey is the HOH rainforest
part of Olympic National Park in
Washington this massive force consists
of nine hundred and twenty-two thousand
acres of unspoiled natural beauty with
the smallest number of roads in the
continental US the whole valley is home
to what's called one square inch of
silence this area marked by a small red
stone is part of a project to encourage
people to listen to their surroundings
while this is supposedly the quietest
natural place in the country you'll
still hear the natural ambience of the
breeze leaves rustling and forest
animals according to one commercial
pilot many airlines have voluntarily
rerouted flights to avoid creating noise
pollution at the square inch of silence
for those of us who just want a break
from the sounds of cars planes and other
man-made distractions Olympic National
Park is the perfect getaway not quiet
enough let's take a look at the crow
Natsuki nature reserve in Russia this
remote fiercely breathtaking landscape
is known as the land of Fire and Ice not
because of any relation to Game of
Thrones but because of its many geysers
and volcanoes the reserve is vast with
trees few and far between and the chilly
climate keeps animal noise to a minimum
though you might encounter the
occasional bear or to crow Natsuki
reserve was created in 1934 and its
current boundary contains an area of
10,000 990 square kilometers or 4240
square miles its main purpose is as an
area for the study of natural sciences
the variety of flora and fauna as well
as mountain ranges and both active and
extinct volcanoes make the reserve the
perfect place to study everything from
biology to chemistry to geology and
everything in between the area is so far
removed from civilization you'll never
see or hear a motor vehicle including
your own that's because the reserve is
so protected you have to sign up with
one of the few approved companies to
shuttle you in on a helicopter and
that's if you're one of the lucky 3,000
people allowed to go per year
if you do manage to get past all the red
tape to visit the reserve be prepared to
pay a fee equivalent to about 700 US
dollars for a one-day trip the crew
Natsuki nature reserve is the ideal spot
for people who appreciate the idea that
statistically speaking even if all three
thousand yearly visitors showed up on
the same day they'd still be separated
from well over 99 percent of the rest of
the people on earth
if the icy climate isn't your idea of
relaxing head over to the Negev desert
in Israel far from the bustling cities
of Jerusalem and Tel Aviv this 13,000
square kilometer expanse of dust and
sand makes up over 55 percent of the
country's land area if you trek further
away from the road into the desert you
can hear your own ears ring from the
silence all you'll hear out there is the
occasional breeze and the dirt crumbling
underfoot for some the silence of the
desert is the most strikingly spiritual
experience of the Holy Land
despite the deserts mostly harsh
landscape there are still a select few
plant and animal species that thrive
there if you're patient and more than a
little lucky you might catch a glimpse
of the endangered Arabian leopard or the
critically endangered negative tortoise
the desert is definitely in stark
contrast to the crow Natsuki reserve
with average temperatures in the warm
season often exceeding 38 degrees
Celsius or 100 degrees Fahrenheit so if
you're planning a trip to the Negev
desert be sure to go in the middle of
summer to avoid as many people as
possible and get a truly silent
experience just remember to bring
sunscreen if the crow not ski reserve is
too cold and the desert is too hot
consider taka a cenote in Tulum Mexico
if you thought it was quiet above-ground
wait till you experience this
subterranean cave not only is this cave
entirely devoid of sound but it's also
completely dark if you're brave turn out
your headlamp and swim out into the
pitch-black water of the cavern for the
ultimate sensory deprivation experience
all you'll be able to hear is your own
breathing and the occasional drop of
water from the stalactites just keep in
mind that while short-term sessions of
sensory deprivation can be very relaxing
and conducive to meditation extended
periods of sensory deprivation can
result in extreme anxiety hallucinations
bizarre thoughts and depression so if
being totally alone and depressed in a
subterranean cave doesn't sound like
your idea of a good time consider one of
the other destinations on our list and
for the final stop on our trip a
man-made Marvel called the anechoic
chamber located in Minnesota according
to the Guinness Book of World Records
the chamber is 90
9.9% sound absorbent running at the
title of the absolute quietest place on
earth you enter the strange room through
large heavy vault style doors the
chamber is constructed of a double layer
of steel and foot thick concrete covered
in crosshatch sound absorbent buffers
and even the floor is suspended by mesh
to avoid any sound from footsteps once
the heavy doors closed behind you the
noise level in the room drops to
negative nine decibels by comparison a
library is usually around 30 decibels
Steven or filled the lab founder says he
challenges people to sit in the room in
the dark and see how long they can last
he says when it's quiet ears will adapt
the quieter of the room the more things
you'll hear you'll hear your heart
beating sometimes you can hear your
lungs hear your stomach gurgling loudly
in the anechoic chamber you become the
sound the longest anyone has lasted in
the room is 45 minutes of course the
room isn't just for unsettling its
visitors when it's not being used as a
torture chamber it serves as a test room
for manufacturers to gauge the volume of
their components it's a fascinating room
and quite the feat of sonic engineering
but not being able to enjoy the silence
for more than a few minutes kind of
defeats the purpose of our hypothetical
trip still for anyone interested in how
the human body sounds in absolute
silence the anechoic chamber is a must
visit so maybe there's such a thing as
too quiet but for anyone who wants the
ultimate noise for you get away you've
got your shortlist these places are the
absolute quietest on earth if you'd like
to learn more about the places on this
list follow the links in the description
remember to follow second thought on
your favorite social media and subscribe
to keep up to date with the latest
content thanks for watching and I'll see
you in the next video